we're all gonna pretend
we're just gonna pretend
that
there was a really good reason
that she was in london and
you know why not london's a really
fascinating place and who wouldn't want
to go over there and stay you know a
couple of decades or so
well
now i'm wondering is tanya baxter
walking through the door with a british
accent well is she
we'll certainly see won't we
what are you doing i'm scared
that's cute but what if someone actually
heard you
takia crystal keema it is so nice to
officially virtually meet you after all
these years i am bursting with
excitement because you are finally
returning to your role as tanya baxter
in the ravens universe how are you
feeling
it is so exciting i i can't even believe
it you know some things were going on in
my personal life when i didn't continue
with the original show i didn't learn
until years later that people
noticed that i was gone
and then it's like over the years where
is she where is she and then when
rondell did a guest spot i was like whoa
i see that dad where's the mop
and they're belligerent writing me what
how come you're like it's not my show i
love this show i watch the show you
should watch this show
you know i'm just thrilled
for me and for my fans that finally
finally
i get to play a character that i created
20 years ago to finally have you back it
feels like such a sweet satisfying
moment for us as fans for you i'm
curious how did this all even come about
they asked me if if i wanted to come
play with them and i said yes it was it
was kind of just that simple was this a
result of raven reaching out to you
which was rondell reaching out to you
i'm not good at keeping up with my tv
daughter but we've stayed in touch and
i've never felt unlike my fans like like
there was some obligation to be on the
show i felt like it is a different show
and it's not the original show and and
we don't have to be on it
whoever she wants to be on it and
whoever the the production wants to be
on should be on it but you know i'm a
fan of shows too and i like when people
come back and you go oh
wow
now they're all together you know i i
have that same excitement so
you know i i don't think i would ever
have said no
it's but i never felt like you know hey
well i'll go you know i just it was a
different show and so
they had asked me
for my availability right before the
pandemic
and then everything shut down
and so they when they asked me again you
know we were like okay for real
can we really do it yeah okay yeah so
i mean i would do anything for raven she
she's you know
just my my heart i i love her so much
i'm so proud of her
uh you know if braven is asking the
answer is yes so we'll work out the
details later because there is such a
jump between when we last saw you and
then where we pick up now have you been
following the episodes did you watch the
last season of that so raven did you
watch corey in the house and have you
been watching raven's home oh my gosh i
watched no television i i was taking
care of my grandmother when when that
that's why i didn't go to the fourth
season of that so raven i i watched my
grandmother's what i watched
for the next two years so no i i that's
why i didn't know until years after
that there was any kind of hullabaloo
about my leaving the show because we
weren't even on the parents weren't even
on every episode and the episodes that
we weren't on
did fine in the race so
yeah no you are so beloved
they're good
you know
and and i remember even at the time when
i told raven you know i can't keep this
up because i was bringing my grandmother
to work with me um
on on the set of that's a raven and
kyle's mom and orlando's mom would watch
her when i was on the set and i would
have to come early to work to give her
time to
to leave time to coax her out of the car
because we would get there and go okay
we're at work it should come
so it just it couldn't be maintained it
it couldn't be maintained
but i talked when i talked to raven i
was like you know uh are if you're okay
with this
and she's like go mom do what you need
to do so
you know i i that the thing you know
coming back
and i thought it was gonna be weird and
it's good that i was so busy
in the weeks proceeding that i didn't
have time to think about it i had three
other scripts in my head and so
and i didn't get the script to this
before until right before we did it or i
might have freaked out because i thought
who is tanya how do i reconstruct her
plus all of these years and all of this
information and i thought it was going
to be a little weird but we came back
to the old set and i got there and i
thought oh i'm home this is my living
room
me tanya baxter this is my kitchen this
is my husband's restaurant the chill
grill oh good
it just felt like i've been away for a
minute and then came back
yeah familiar territory i have to
imagine and can i just say it is
so commendable and admirable in my heart
that you made that heartbreaking
decision to put family before your own
career and now that you
you know you had the time to do that and
to step back into these tanya baxter
shoes um i don't know that just that
that that feels wild to me
it it was wild but it was you know just
because when i'm when i'm doing
something i'm all in
so i
she tanya baxter was so familiar to me
that it was easy to jump back into her
shoes literally
and to have rondell there and to have
raven there
it just was so familiar and because i've
seen this show
when i looked at isaac i thought well
that's my grandson okay so i know you
can't spill too much but here's what we
do know we know that tonya baxter
returns from england she comes and
visits the baxters in san francisco to
help celebrate her husband victor's 60th
birthday what can you tell me about what
we can expect in the season five finale
ah
i don't know i i mean i think that
it's all i think all i could say and
should say is that it's a surprise to
everyone when i show up
because so it's even a surprise to raven
and to her father on the show they had
no idea that mama baxter was coming back
right wow oh my gosh so
how does that impact the 60th birthday
celebration are you sharing tender
moments are there more comedic moments
well we'll certainly see
you're giving me nothing
i know i'm sure
yeah there was a mixed reaction but
they're happy to see me can you tell me
how are tonya and victor making a
long-distance marriage work
well okay so so this is this is how i
see it
it's television and in television we
pretend things
and so
we suspend our disbelief
and you know i've created lots of
stories because you know when you're an
actor it has to make sense to you yes
and so in my mind
not this is not coming from the show
this is coming from me
that i went to london to finish my
studies
because i got an incredible scholarship
that i couldn't pass and i always wanted
to go to london
and i thought if i go there you know
they'll come they'll eventually come
with me
and instead i got great offer after
great offer after great offer and and in
my mind i've come back and forth
you just don't see it on the shows sure
but i haven't been gone this whole time
i'm just gone when the shows are taping
[Laughter]
okay so the advice to the audience is
use your imagination this is a family
that is seeing each other you're just
not seeing it yes we're all gonna
pretend
we're just gonna pretend
that
there was a really good reason that she
was in london and
you know why not london's a really
fascinating place and who wouldn't want
to go over there and stay you know a
couple of decades or so
well
now i'm wondering is tanya baxter
walking through the door with a british
accent well is she well we'll certainly
see won't we
if there is fingers crossed a season six
would you want to come back
full time or maybe even in just a more
frequent capacity
well and and i
uh
i i hope there is a season six let me
say that clear with or without me i
really hope there's a season six because
it's a wonderful show and ever those
children
ah
every time but certainly if they ask me
i'd come back of course i and i think it
would be lovely and cute i love that
you're a fan and you know that your fans
would seriously hope to see more of you
if fingers crossed there is a season six
they're already they're already
saying that they're already demanding it
more than a few people like it's more
about time
what took you so long
you better have come on there um
listen i hope we answered all of those
things in this interview i hope so too i
hope i'm just i'm happy that they're
happy and
that it all worked out some people are
saying oh the family's all back together
but you know who we're missing
you know we're missing my baby kyle and
so he wasn't on this show but we
facetimed him well i was there and so we
did it all together and that was
wonderful what did what went down in
that facetime was it laughs was it
reconnecting with the first minute he
was just screaming
he was not expecting to see you in tanya
baxter mode i imagine no no because she
called him first and she had you know so
he just saw him and she goes okay so i
have with me
she turned
and he was like
is that is that is it
i've always said i have the best family
in the world and that includes all of my
fans and i really really really
appreciate them
[Music]